[Music]
rick and morty season five is coming and
it's
sure to be full of all the little
details and subtle jokes that we've come
to expect
here are a few we saw in the new trailer
in the trailer there's a strange looking
character with slicked back hair
pale blue lips gills on his neck and
very little clothing this guy is
actually someone rick to test
more than any other creature in any
other universe
and the rick and morty season 5 trailer
isn't the first time fans have caught a
glimpse of him
back in july 2020 adult swim released a
first look clip from the upcoming season
which features incomplete animation of
rick and morty escaping monsters on a
ravaged planet
morty driving rick's ship and dodging
flaming asteroids
and then crashing the ship in the ocean
rick immediately panics and
then the merman emerges from a giant
clam shell to taunt rick and morty
his name is mr nimbus and he's rick's
once
and eternal foe who the [ __ ] is that my
nemesis what my nemesis okay okay but
what was his name again
i am mr nimbus another short sequence in
the season five trailer depicts morty
carrying an injured rick through a
landscape
dotted with floating crystals that look
like a good place to store renegade
kryptonian generals
in rick and morty however these crystals
aren't gateways to the phantom zone
rather they seem to reveal alternate
universe versions of rick and morty
and it wouldn't be the show we all know
and love if at least one of these
alternate realities didn't show rick and
morty as superheroes as the pair trek
through the field of crystals rick is
quick to point out the crystal that
shows the reality
in which they are both versions of the
half vampiric vampire killing marvel
hero blade
famously played on screen by wesley
snipes this seems to be a clever
reference to the bloody rave scene from
blade
the blade universe crystal is only on
screen for a few seconds in the rick and
morty season 5
trailer but it isn't the only one that
bears weight
way in the back of the same shot is
another significant
crystal one that references rick and
morty's origins
in the crystal morty's wearing a blue
shirt and a red vest while rick still
rocks his signature white lab coat
if upon closer inspection this looks
familiar to fans
it's because they've almost definitely
seen these exact iterations of rick and
morty before
this crystal's reality is a callback to
the real animated adventures of doc and
marty
made by rick and morty co-creator justin
roiland in 2006.
this very not safe for work short
parodies the classic back to the future
film series and
ultimately formed the basis for rick and
morty i can't guess you guys aren't
ready for that yet
but your kids are gonna love it part of
the fun of rick and morty
is all the clever satire of popular
sci-fi and fantasy properties and
season five looks to continue this
tradition by taking aim at two ips in
particular
a common sight in the trailer is the
smith sanchez family geared up in a set
of matching color-coded suits this feels
like a clear reference to the classic
80s cartoon voltron
the trailer also seems to give a hat tip
to another popular kids tv series
transformers early on in the rick and
morty season 5 trailer we see rick's
ship facing off against a humanoid robot
that bears a striking resemblance to a
transformer
with car parts making up certain
portions of its body
at several points in the trailer rick
and beth are seen wearing some gruesome
costumes that look straight out of a
horror movie
fittingly they are from a horror movie
or rather a horror franchise
these outfits prove that the series will
reference the late 80s horror film
hellraiser in at least
one upcoming episode the whole universe
in which rick and beth wear these
costumes appears to be a parody of the
hellraiser world
and the getups look like mildly toned
down versions of what the film's extra
dimensional cenobite beings wear
the darts in beth's space feel like a
clever twist on the iron nails that the
film's main antagonist pinhead has all
over his
face additionally in the background of
one scene from the trailer are two
creatures who appear to be riffs on
hellraiser's creepier cenobites
in particular the one with no eyes and
who bears
all of its teeth looks exactly like
chatterer hellraiser's right-hand man
the one between rick and beth with half
of its face splayed open
could be a very subtle reference to
angelique from hellraiser bloodline
though it's more likely that this one is
a rick and morty original
the thought of his long time crush
jessica being a significant part of his
life is enough to make morty scream
until he passes out
that thought will apparently become a
reality in rick and morty season 5 as
the trailer shows two separate instances
in which
jessica appears as part of smith sanchez
family adventures
though she has been seen in missions
with the crew before some were
non-canonical and these season 5 moments
hold
much more weight early in the trailer
there's a scene involving giant
transformers-esque robots upon first
glance it looks like rick
morty and summer are in the battle arena
but it's actually rick
morty and jessica why would jessica be
involved in such a strange quest
the answer lies in the first look clip
from season 5
the same one that revealed mr nimbus in
that clip morty calls jessica and
confesses his affection for her
much to morty's surprise jessica admits
she has feelings for morty too
and invites him to watch a movie with
her that night though it's not explained
in the new trailer that moment
should happen in season 5 and mark the
beginning of a relationship
between jessica and morty of course the
most important detail in the whole
trailer comes
right at the end new episodes of rick
and morty will be portaling into this
universe on
adult swim on sunday june 20th at 11 pm
eastern time check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one